touchdown in north china's inner
mongolia
three taken out that's chinese
astronauts are on solid ground after six
months in space
first to be pulled out of the capsule
mission commander xi jing gong
we thank president xi jinping for his
concern and care we thank the people for
their support and encouragement
he was followed by colleagues wong
yaping and ya guang
13 mission recorded a few firsts for
china wang became the first chinese
woman to complete a space walk and it
was china's longest crude mission
the spaceship was launched from jioquan
satellite launch center in the gobi
desert in mid-october
hours later it docked with china's
unfinished orbital space station
tiangong
there the astronauts got to work
carrying out experiments and preparing
for the construction of new space
modules and delivering science lectures
that included answering questions from
these keen students back on earth
so what's next for beijing
while china has put billions of dollars
into space programs it hopes to send
humans to the moon by 2029 and build a
base there
but for now the take not trio have
wrapped up their mission and will no
doubt be spending time adjusting to
gravity here on earth
laura about manly al jazeera